[Music]
this is LARPing you may have heard about
it from movies like Knights of Badassdom
or role models but what exactly is
LARPing and why are people so obsessed
with it LARP is an acronym lar P it
stands for live-action role-playing some
people will say live-action role-playing
game or they'll turn it into a verb
called LARPing Chelsey Russell has been
LARPing for the past 7 years going about
once a month she's part of a group of
LARPers based in New Jersey called
aural what LARP is is generally a
interactive role-playing experience kind
of like a Johnston's and Dragons or a
video game come to real life
LARPing basically involves coming up
with a character giving it a background
making costumes and props for it and
then acting out a story we're currently
in Stage point Delta of the continent of
Antioch you determine their name their
personality you know do they have any
family members what's their goals in
life this is my character likes math the
basic plot has been written in advance
and players used that as a launchpad to
improvise the rest they've created a
world and they've created rules for that
world
Aurum is a steampunk fantasy themed LARP
some other LARP scan' be
post-apocalyptic zombie and vampire
themed in addition to participating as a
player Chelsea also writes some of the
stories and works part-time on the staff
we spent the weekend at one of arms
monthly events to see what it's like
this LARP took place at a Boy Scout camp
in New Jersey which was closed for the
season so all the cabins and buildings
were free for use one of the organizers
Robin arrived early to set up food and
decorations soon the players who
registered in advance started to show up
in their cars when players arrive
they'll arrive out of game out of
character you know setting up their
things and if it's a
weaken think they'll be setting up their
sleeping area weekend LARP stip eclis
run from Friday night through Saturday
at midnight they cost around forty to
fifty dollars to register per person
which doesn't include travel or any meal
besides breakfast about ten people were
in attendance for this event when they
registered they get their character
sheet with their current stats along
with some cards that represent weapons
and ingredients used to make items one
of the things that people can make in
the game is called a clockwork messenger
it's supposed to be a small animal often
in the shape of a dog that can carry
messages for people a few people will
take turns playing what's called an NPC
think of them as temporary staff working
for the writers and organizers the term
is called NPC non-player character
they'll send an NPC out as I'm a nasty
orc and I'm going to burn down your farm
and the players will react as they
determine that their characters react as
they got into costume the players ate
dinner together I'm Silas explore Edmund
sterling he's a known entrepreneur we
honor ROS she's an imperial scientist my
character's name is the mold he has an
actual name but he doesn't remember it
anymore he's a hedge mage so he's one of
the people who tried to cling on to the
dying magic of this world meanwhile
boram's head of plot kelvin started
setting up his props
I've been LARPing since 1995 Kelvin
brought various items including light-up
wreaths fake plants stuffed creatures
and lots of fake weapons Orem is a type
of LARP called a combat boffer larp
combat boffer larp
have an element of physicality to them
they incorporate specially made weapons
that you can actually fight with just
PVC pipe covered with insulation foam
and duct tape and made in such a way to
represent a sword or an axe or a hammer
what have you since its steampunk themed
there are also guns we use nerf guns
with this game but I painted this one
specifically
would fit the theme a little better like
with coppers and Silver's if you get hit
by one of the bullets it takes real hip
points off your character a little bit
more it's a continuous storyline for a
month a month so there's a lot to catch
up on everyone evacuated this area cool
yeah let's get ready to rock starting 15
on Friday night Chelsea would be playing
as an MPC
and Marshall Marshalls wear white
headbands or hats to distinguish
themselves from the players I'm out of
game I'm not in character I'm not
something to interact with they're
asking you may be game mechanic
questions that like can I use this skill
or how does this thing work the marshals
will have the notes for the different
encounters or what they're doing on
these tablets tonight I will be playing
a one of the departed spirits that has
remained in the abandoned town
my main goal will just to be as spooky
and creepy as possible
a couple days after Halloween when all
the costume goes on sale we jokingly
referred to as larper Christmas but so
you can go to the stores and get all of
your costume needs for cheap I actually
was the one who mainly wrote the events
of tonight the story started at a
basketball court on camp is it go
Bernard Bynum the main plot of the
weekend is that the characters are
trying to reclaim a town called stage
point Delta which had been overrun with
orcs several months ago and it's now
inhabited by a number of creatures
including ghosts one of which could be
put to rest only after burying his bones
his bones run fortunately one of the
players brought a shovel a Coon's
raccoons are also creature you can
encounter and they have specific skills
that have been written down they also
were faced with other challenges like a
puzzle they had to solve to clear the
way to enter a building the first line
is sod talk or bees query make second
line is down eve is upon dine tree once
inside a demon was waiting to do battle
in armed characters can die they can be
permanently killed but that doesn't mean
you have to go home you can jump in as a
new character or if you're only wounded
you can also be healed someone can come
along and say I'm applying first aid and
then you would be able to stand back up
and you would may roleplay oh I've been
stabbed through the chest it hurts but
I'm alive the game went on until about 3
a.m. after patrolling the perimeter to
make sure the land was secure
in the morning Robin made pancakes and
bacon for the players who arrived at the
table in costume and in character on
Saturday
Chelsea became one of the players and
someone else took on the role of
Marshall and MPC so my usual character
is a CAF mathematician she follows the
Sun God called happenin my name is
Madeline Epstein Ehrhoff I'm a van Ness
a mathematician with stone forging
company in the daylight the group
battled some more creatures like a tiger
and a troll and things got a bit scary
when real gunshots could be heard in the
woods from nearby hunters but they
managed to tie this into the game story
[Music]
while I was filming no one was on their
phones taking selfies or posting to
Facebook while in character tends to
break people out of their mindset of
playing their character and once you
start playing in character you generally
try not to talk about things that are
real-world related you wouldn't talk
about oh my car broke down there was
also no drinking at this LARP
everyone played for the rest of the day
and then departed on Sunday back to the
real world my real life job I am a
supervisor at a coffee shop and then I
come here and I play math nerds and
ghosts many of them will be back next
month to continue the story it's fun to
play pretend and a lot of people I think
think that dressing up and playing
pretend is childish when it doesn't have
to be the enjoyment you get is creating
a story together with people and I think
that's something that a lot of people
don't really realize
[Music]